it's not about you know that one thing
that you do or you don't do it's about
the holistic view we got together and um
under the banner of the American gut
project I think what was really
important about the study is that it
showed as long as you at 30
types of plant and that's including nuts
and seeds and Herb mixes and spices it
didn't matter whether you had a little
bit of meat a little bit of fish you
were vegan vegetarian whatever your gut
health was still optimal what can you
get on your plate if three quarters of
it's filled with a giant steak there's
not much room for your plants everyone
needs to know much more about gut health
and the microbiome and treat it you know
just as you would look after it like you
would your heart